What is why do so many people say to drink apple cider vinegar?
I see somebody posted hits to grab about apple cider vinegar. What would be the rationale?
Okay, so apple cider vinegar is
a mild acid to see the acid so
Why would you take apple cider vinegar?
Well, your stomach
has to have
a pH that's
relatively very acidic. So your stomach pH is at about 1.5 to 2.0. That's very acidic. The acid that
creates the acidic environment in the stomach is hydrochloric acid
produced by these cells in the stomach called as Pridal cells in the stomach and you need to have that
level of acidity in your stomach for multiple reasons. That's how you break down
proteins and carbohydrates in the stomach where you start the process of digestion that is
breaking down food in the small particles so that you can absorb them. That coupled with the
talent that's secreted by your salivary gland, HCl, that's in the stomach, combines in the
dewandum once that that bolus of food goes into the swallow tested,
more partially digested, combines in the dewandum with the enzymes secreted from the pancreas,
and then combines with the bile
which helps break down fat and get rid of toxins from the gallbladder from the liver.
So you need an acidic stomach and one could argue that the lack of acidity in your stomach
mainly caused from a lack of production of hydrochloric acid by the Pridal cells,
mainly because of poor diet, chemicals, toxins, dyes,
additives, colorings, flavorings, poisons, toxins, GM, GMO, foods, etc.,
damage those Pridal cells so you don't get it a production of HCl. So then your stomach is
relatively alkaline, food is not getting digested, worse things happen,
you don't secret intrinsic factor, necessary for vitamin B12 absorption. So that whole
condition is called hypochloridorya, decreased hydrochloric acid in the stomach. That's what leads
to leaky gut issues because you are not getting food properly digested, broken down,
putting a lot more stress on the pancreas, one theory why the increase in pancreatic cancer exists
in the largement of pancreas, pancreas overall, and pancreatitis, also it increase stress on the
liver and bowel bladder. So food is not getting broken down into its proper size molecules,
so proteins are not getting broken down into dipeptides or amino acids. They go into the small attested
into the larger tested as larger peptides and can damage the gut walls, along with all sorts of
toxins and GMO foods that you ate that damaged the gut wall. Now they can cross the gut border
as larger peptides you develop antibodies against different foods, now you have food sensitivities.
Every time you eat those foods now you develop a inflammatory reaction of the gut, that inflammatory
reaction that gut causes further degradation of the epithelial layer of the gut damaging, more
gut cells increasing the leaky gut issues. It's just a giant ball of wax problem, so you could solve a
lot of problems by taking HCl and digestive enzymes with each meal, or if your stomach can't tolerate
that because you've had this damage for so long, many times you also have an ulcer, so you can't even
take HCl because it causes such very strong stabbing stomachache. You can start with apple cider vinegar
and see if it sits a little bit milder acid, and see if you can tolerate that. If you can't tolerate
that, you have to go back and just try to heal the gut, heal the stomach with something like
deglycerized licorice. Now I have a blog post on this, if you go to our website cuttersclinic.com,
you'll see a blog post that goes through all the different steps about this,
and just search hypochloridria, or HCl, hypochloridria, or something like that. Search for HCl
on stomach issues, and you'll find a blog post about this.